De telles images, venant du camp de concentration d'Auschwitz,
ont été enracinées dans notre conscience pendant le 20e siècle
et nous ont donné une nouvelle compréhension de qui nous sommes,
d'où nous venons, et de notre époque.
Lors du 20e siècle, nous avons assisté aux atrocités
de Staline, Hitler, Mao, Pol Pot, du Rwanda et à d'autres génocides,
et bien que le 21e siècle n'ait que 7 ans,
nous avons déjà vu un génocide au Darfur
et les horreurs quotidiennes en Iraq.
Cela nous amène à mal comprendre notre situation :
nous pensons que le progrès nous a amené une violence terrible, et que
les peuplades primitives vivaient dans un état d'harmonie que nous avons perdu.
Voici un exemple tiré
d'une tribune du Boston Globe le jour de Thanksgiving
il y a quelques années. L'auteur écrit : "La vie des Indiens d'Amérique
était difficile, mais il n'y avait pas de problèmes de chômage,
la communauté vivait en harmonie, il n'y avait pas d'abus de drogues,
pas de crimes, et les seules guerres étaient entre tribus,
et étaient surtout rituelles, ne se transformant que rarement
en massacre." Vous connaissez ce genre de niaiseries.
On l'apprend à nos enfants ; on l'entend à la télévision
et dans les livres d'histoire. Le titre original de cette session
était "Tout ce que vous savez est faux", et je vais vous montrer des preuves
que cette part de notre connaissance commune est erronée :
que nos ancêtres étaient beaucoup plus violents que nous le sommes,
que la violence est en baisse depuis très longtemps,
et que nous vivons durant ce qui est probablement la période la plus paisible de l'existence de notre espèce.
Dans la décennie qui a vu le Darfour et l'Iraq,
cette idée peut paraitre entre hallucinante
et obscène. Mais je vais essayer de vous convaincre
que c'est la vérité. Le déclin de la violence
est un phénomène fractal. On le voit sur des millénaires,
des siècles, des décennies et des années,
même s'il semble qu'il y ait eu un point de basculement au début
de l'Age de Raison au 16e siècle. On le voit
à travers le monde, mais pas de façon homogène.
C'est particulièrement évident à l'ouest, en commençant par l'Angleterre
et la Hollande au temps des Lumières.
Voyageons dans le temps à différentes échelles --
du millénaire à l'année --
pour vous en convaincre. Jusqu'à 10 000 ans avant aujourd'hui, tous les hommes
vivaient de la chasse et la cueillette, sans habitations permanentes
ni gouvernement. Et on considère généralement cet état comme étant
un état d'harmonie originelle. Mais l'archéologue
Lawrence Keeley, qui a étudié les taux de décès
des tribus contemporaines de chasseurs-cueilleurs -- qui sont notre
meilleure source de données sur cette façon de vivre -- a tiré une conclusion assez différente.
Voici le graphique qu'il a réalisé
qui montre le pourcentage de morts masculines dues à la guerre
dans un certain nombre de tribus de chasseurs-cueilleurs.
Les barres rouges correspondent à la probabilité qu'un homme soit tué
par un autre homme, au lieu de mourir de
causes naturelles, dans différentes sociétés de chasseurs-cueilleurs
en Nouvelle-Guinée et dans la forêt amazonienne.
Elles vont d'un taux de presque 60% de chances qu'un homme soit tué
par un autre, jusqu'à, dans le cas des Gebusis,
seulement 15%. La petite barre bleue en bas à gauche
montre la même statistique aux États-Unis et
en Europe au 20e siècle, qui inclus tous les morts
des deux guerres mondiales. Si le taux de mortalité des guerres tribales était resté le même
au cours du 20e siècle, il y aurait eu 2 milliards de morts, et non 100 millions.
A l'échelle du millénaire, on peut étudier
la façon de vivre des premières civilisations, telles celles décrites
dans la Bible. Et dans ce qui est censé être une source de nos valeurs morales,
on peut lire des descriptions de ce qu'étaient les guerres,
comme cet extrait de Nombres 31 : "Ils s'avancèrent
contre Madian, selon l'ordre que l'Éternel avait donné à Moïse ;
et ils tuèrent tous les mâles. Et Moïse leur dit :
"Avez-vous laissé la vie à toutes les femmes ? Maintenant, tuez tout mâle
parmi les petits enfants, et tuez toute femme qui a connu un homme
en couchant avec lui ; mais laissez en vie pour vous toutes les filles
qui n'ont point connu la couche d'un homme." En d'autres termes,
Tuez les hommes, tuez les enfants, et si vous rencontrez des vierges
vous pouvez les laisser en vie pour les violer.
On trouve 4 ou 5 passages dans la Bible de cet acabit.
Dans la Bible, on voit aussi que la peine de mort
était la punition habituelle pour des crimes tels que l'homosexualité,
l'adultère, le blasphème, l'idolâtrie, le fait de répondre à ses parents --
(Rires) -- et de ramasser du bois pendant le Sabbat.
Avançons à présent
à l'échelle du siècle
Nous n'avons pas de statistiques concernant les guerres depuis
le Moyen Âge jusqu'aux temps modernes,
mais nous savons de l'Histoire -- les preuves
ont toujours été sous nos yeux -- qu'il y a eu une réduction
des formes de violence acceptées par la société.
Par exemple, l'Histoire nous apprend que les mutilations et la torture
étaient une punition habituelle pour les criminels. Le genre d'infraction
qui aujourd'hui vous donnerait une amende vous causait au Moyen Âge
d'avoir la langue ou les oreilles coupées, d'être rendu aveugle,
d'avoir une main tranchée, et ainsi de suite.
Il y avait d'innombrables formes de peines capitales sadiques :
brulé vif, éviscéré, passé au supplice de la roue,
écartelé par des chevaux et ainsi de suite.
La peine de mort était la punition pour un grand nombre de crimes non violents :
critiquer le Roi, voler une miche de pain. L'esclavage, bien sûr,
était la méthode favorite d'économie de main d'oeuvre, et la cruauté était
une forme de divertissement populaire. L'exemple le plus éloquent
est la coutume de bruler un chat, où l'animal était hissé sur une
estrade puis descendu par un harnais dans un feu ;
les spectateurs éclataient de rire tandis que le chat, hurlant de douleur,
était brulé vif.
Et en ce qui concerne les meurtres ? Là nous avons de bonnes statistiques,
puisque beaucoup de villes enregistraient les causes de décès.
Le criminologue Manuel Eisner
a parcouru les archives historiques à travers l'Europe
à la recherche des taux de meurtres dans tous les villages, hameaux, villes et comtés
qu'il a pu trouver, et les a complétées
par les données nationales, quand les pays ont commencé à conserver des statistiques.
Il les a représentées sur une échelle logarithmique, allant de 100 morts
pour 100.000 habitants par an, ce qui est environ le taux
d'homicide au Moyen Âge. Le taux chute
à moins d'un homicide pour 100.000 personnes par an
dans sept ou huit pays européens. Il y a ensuite une légère augmentation
dans les années 60. Les gens qui pensaient que le Rock n' roll allait
détruire nos valeurs morales n'avaient pas tout à fait tord.
Mais il y a eu une baisse de deux ordres de grandeur
du nombre d'homicides depuis le Moyen Âge jusqu'à nos jours,
et le point de bascule est survenu au début du 16e siècle.
Voyons à présent à l'échelle de la décennie.
D'après les organisations non gouvernementales
qui gardent ce genre de statistiques, depuis 1945 en Europe et aux Amériques
il y a eu une baisse rapide des guerres entre états,
des coups militaires, des émeutes ethniques,
même en Amérique du Sud. Dans le monde entier, il y a eu une baisse rapide
des tués pendant les guerres. Les barres jaunes ici montrent le nombre
de morts par guerre par an, depuis 1950 jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Comme vous pouvez le voir, le taux de mortalité chute de 65.000 morts
par conflit par an dans les années 1950, jusqu'à 2.000 morts
par conflit par an dans cette décennie, aussi horrible qu'elle soit.
Même à l'échelle annuelle, on peut voir une baisse de la violence.
Depuis la fin de la guerre froide, il y a eu moins de guerres civiles,
moins de génocides -- une réduction de 90% depuis les chiffres élevés de la Seconde Guerre mondiale --
et même une inversion du pic des années 60 concernant les meurtres et crimes violents.
Ceci est tiré des statistiques criminelles du FBI : on peut voir
un taux de violence assez bas dans les années 50 et 60,
puis en forte augmentation pendant plusieurs décennies,
puis en forte baisse, depuis les années 90, et qui est revenu
presque au niveau des années 1960.
Président Clinton, si vous êtes ici, merci.
(Rires)
La question est donc : pourquoi tant de gens se trompent au sujet
de quelque chose de si important ? Je pense qu'il y a plusieurs raisons,
l'une d'entre elles étant que nous avons un meilleur journalisme. L'Associated Press (AP)
rend un meilleur compte des guerres
que les moines du 16e siècle.
Il y a aussi une illusion cognitive : les psychologues cognitifs comme moi savons que plus il est facile
de se souvenir de quelque chose,
plus on lui attribue une forte probabilité.
Ce que l'on lit dans le journal, accompagné de photos affreuses
est plus facilement enregistré en mémoire que les statistiques sur le nombre de gens
qui meurent de vieillesse dans leur lit. Il y a aussi une dynamique du marché
de l'opinion : personne n'a jamais attiré d'observateurs, de défenseurs
et de donateurs en disant
"les choses vont de mieux en mieux."
(Rires)
Nous nous sentons coupables du traitement des peuplades primitives
dans le monde moderne, et refusons d'admettre
qu'il pourrait y avoir quelque chose de positif dans la culture occidentale.
Et, bien sûr, nos standards changent plus vite que nous ne changeons
de comportement. Une des raisons pour laquelle le taux de violence a baissé
est que les gens en ont eu assez du carnage et de la cruauté de leur époque.
C'est un processus qui continue,
mais s'il évalue les comportements selon les standards du jour,
les choses paraissent toujours plus sauvages qu'elles ne le sont,
comparées à l'histoire. De nos jours, on est indignés -- à juste titre --
quand des assassins sont tués par injection léthale
au Texas, au bout de 15 ans d'appels. Mais nous ne pensons pas au fait
qu'il y a quelques centaines d'années, ils auraient pu avoir été envoyés au bucher
pour avoir critiqué le roi, après un procès
de 10 minutes -- et que ce genre de chose aurait été fréquent.
De nos jours, nous voyons la peine de mort comme
une preuve de l'aspect indigne de nos comportements,
plutôt que de la façon dont nos standards se sont élevés.
Pourquoi la violence est-elle en déclin ? Personne ne le sait vraiment,
mais j'ai lu quatre explications, qui toutes, à mon avis,
ont une part de crédibilité. La première est : peut-être
que Thomas Hobbes avait raison. Il soutenait que
la vie dans le monde naturel était "solitaire, pauvre, sale, brutale
et courte." Pas parce que, selon lui,
les hommes ont un gout primordial pour le sang,
ou un instinct agressif, ou un impératif territorial,
mais à cause de la logique de l'anarchie. Dans un état d'anarchie
il y a une tentation constante d'envahir ses voisins préventivement,
avant qu'ils ne vous envahissent. Récemment, Thomas Schelling
donnait l'analogie d'un propriétaire qui entend un bruit dans
sa cave. Comme tout bon Américain, il a son arme sur
la table de chevet, la prend et descend les marches.
En bas il voit un cambrioleur, arme à la main.
Chacun pense :
"Je ne veux pas tuer ce type, mais il va me tuer.
Je devrais peut être lui tirer dessus avant qu'il ne le fasse,
surtout que, même s'il ne veut pas me tuer,
il est sans doute en train de penser que je vais le tuer
avant qu'il ne me tue". Et ainsi de suite.
Les chasseurs-cueilleurs ont le même raisonnement,
et attaquent souvent leurs voisins, de peur d’être envahis les premiers.
Une façon d'éluder ce problème est la dissuasion :
vous n'attaquez pas, mais vous faites savoir que
les représailles seront sauvages si vous êtes attaqué.
Le seul risque avec cette méthode est qu'on peut
penser que vous bluffez ; elle ne fonctionne donc que
si elle est crédible. Pour ce faire, vous devez répondre à chaque insulte
et résoudre chaque conflit, ce qui mène à des cycles de vendettas sanglantes.
La vie devient un épisode des Sopranos. La solution de Hobbes,
le "Léviathan", est que si la décision de l'usage
de la violence était laissée à un unique système démocratique, un Léviathan,
alors cela réduirait la tentation d'attaquer,
puisque tout acte d'agression serait puni,
réduisant sa profitabilité à zéro. Voilà qui enlèverait la tentation
d'envahir de manière préventive, de peur qu'on ne vous attaque en premier.
Plus besoin de représailles immédiates
pour que la dissuasion soit crédible. Ainsi, on obtiendrait un
état de paix. Eisner -- celui qui a analysé les taux d'homicide que
vous n'avez pas vu dans la diapositive précédente --
propose que le déclin du nombre d'homicides en Europe
coïncide avec l'arrivée des États centralisés.
Cela donne du poids à la théorie du Léviathan.
Une autre preuve est qu'aujourd'hui on observe une explosion de la violence
dans les zones d'anarchie : États défaillants, empires anéantis,
zones frontières, mafias, gangs, etc.
La seconde raison est qu'à de nombreux moments et dans de nombreux endroits
il y a un sentiment partagé qu'une vie ne vaut pas grand-chose.
Autrefois, quand la souffrance et la mort prématurée étaient choses communes,
on avait moins de scrupules à les infliger à quelqu'un d'autre.
Alors que la technologie et les progrès économiques rendent la vie
plus longue et plus agréable, on donne une plus grande valeur à la vie en général.
Il s'agit d'un argument de science politique de James Payne.
Une troisième explication utilise le concept de "jeu à somme non-nulle",
et a été présenté dans le livre "Non-Zero", du journaliste
Robert Wright. Wright montre que dans certaines circonstances
la coopération, qui inclus la non-violence, peut être bénéfique aux deux parties
d'une interaction, comme les gains d'un échange, quand chaque parti décide
de partager ses surplus, et que les deux en tirent profit, ou quand deux partis
déposent les armes et se partagent les dividendes de la paix
ce qui a pour conséquence qu'ils n'ont plus à se battre en permanence.
Wright soutient que la technologie a augmenté le nombre
de jeux à somme positive entre les hommes,
en permettant l'échange de biens, de services et d'idées
sur des plus grandes distances et avec de plus grands groupes de personnes.
Au final, les gens ont une plus grande valeur vivants que morts,
et la violence baisse, pour des raisons égoïstes. Wright écrit :
"Parmi toutes les raisons pour lesquelles nous ne devrions pas bombarder
les japonnais, est qu'ils fabriquent mon minivan."
(Rires)
La 4e explication est contenue dans le titre d'un livre
appelé "The Expanding Circle", du philosophe Peter Singer,
qui soutient que l'évolution a donné aux humains un sens
de l'empathie : la capacité de traiter les intérêts des autres
comme les nôtres. Malheureusement, nous ne l'appliquons habituellement
qu'à un cercle très restreint d'amis et de membres de notre famille.
Les gens en dehors de ce cercle sont considérés comme sous-humains,
et peuvent être exploités avec impunité. Mais au cours de l'histoire,
ce cercle s'est agrandi. On peut voir, historiquement,
que le cercle s'agrandit du village, au clan, à la tribu,
puis à la nation, aux autres "races", aux deux sexes
et, selon Singer, ce cercle devrait s'étendre aux autres
espèces sensibles. La question est,
si c'est ce qui c'est passé, qu'est-ce qui a provoqué cette expansion ?
Il y a plusieurs possibilités. Une augmentation du cercle
de réciprocité, selon l'expression de Robert Wright.
La logique de la règle d'or : plus vous pensez à, et faites des échanges
avec d'autres personnes, plus vous vous rendez compte qu'il est intolérable
de privilégier vos intérêts par rapport aux leurs,
du moins si vous voulez qu'ils vous écoutent. Vous ne pouvez pas dire
que mes intérêts sont meilleurs que les vôtres,
pas plus que vous ne pouvez dire que l'endroit
où je me trouve est un endroit unique de l'Univers
simplement par ce que je m'y trouve en ce moment.
L'expansion peut aussi être alimentée par le multiculturalisme ; par les histoires,
le journalisme, les mémoires, la fiction réaliste, les voyages
et l'alphabétisation, qui nous permettent de nous imaginer dans la vie
d'autres personnes, qu'on aurait peut-être traité de sous-humains autrefois,
et de se rendre compte des hasards qui nous ont menés là où nous sommes,
de se dire "c'est par chance que je suis là."
Quelles qu'en soient les causes, le déclin de la violence
a de profondes conséquences. Cela devrait nous forcer à nous demander
non seulement "Pourquoi la guerre ?" mais aussi "Pourquoi la paix ?". Pas seulement
"Que faisons-nous mal ?", mais aussi "Que faisons-nous bien ?"
Car nous faisons quelque chose de bien,
et ça serait bien de découvrir ce que c'est.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements).
Chris Anderson : J'ai adoré cette session. Je pense que de nombreuses personnes ici diraient
que l'expansion de -- dont vous parliez,
dont parle Peter Singer, est aussi alimentée par la technologie,
par une plus grande visibilité des autres, et par le sentiment que le monde
devient plus petit. Est-ce que c'est possible ?
Steven Pinker : Tout à fait. Cela correspond aux théories de Wright,
à savoir que ça nous permet de bénéficier de la coopération
avec des cercles de plus en plus grands. Mais je pense que ça nous permet aussi
de nous imaginer dans la peau de quelqu'un d'autre. Je pense que quand on lit
les récits de ces horribles tortures qui étaient communes au Moyen Âge,
on se demande comment ils ont pu,
comment ils n'ont pas eu d'empathie pour la personne
qu'ils éviscéraient ? Clairement,
de leur point de vue, leur victime était un être étrange
dépourvu des mêmes sentiments qu'eux. Je pense que tout
ce qui nous facilite de nous imaginer à la place d'un autre
augmente nos considérations morales
envers cette personne.
CA : Et bien, Steve, j'aimerai que tous les propriétaires de médias entendent cette session
durant l'année à venir. Je pense que c'est vraiment important. Merci beaucoup.
SP : Le plaisir est pour moi.